so there was a story that a school
district in virginia was banning dr
seuss on charges that dr seuss was
racist but cnn has the article running
cover for this cancellation attempt
um as best they can
let me pull it up here it says a school
district in virginia recently made
headlines for allegedly banning
books uh books by dr seuss but lou down
county public schools located in ashburn
said it is not banning books by the
famous children's author is just
discouraging a connection between read
across america which was created to get
kids excited about reading
and dr seuss's birthday both follow
march 2nd
and have often been historically
connected to each other according to the
district
it said in a statement research in
recent years has revealed strong racial
undertones in many books written
illustrated by dr seuss um
and examples of racial undertones in the
books include anti-japanese american
political cartoons and cartoons
depicting african-americans for sale
captioned with offensive language this
according to the lcps
uh given this research and lcps's focus
on equity and culturally responsive
instruction
lcps provided this guidance to schools
during the past couple of years to not
connect read across america day
exclusively
with dr seuss's books so that's the um
that's the claim at least as it pertains
to the school systems and read across
america
that well they're not they're not
canceling the books they're just
de-emphasizing them
which read as canceling them
but it goes beyond the school systems so
here's the latest
um from mediaite this is what they
report
the official organization that controls
the legacy of dr seuss has announced it
will see sales of six of the author's
children's books over racist and
insensitive depictions
in a statement time for the late
author's birthday
uh dr seuss enterprises told the
associated press that the books here are
the books
and to think that i saw it on may
mulberry street if i ran the zoo
mcelligot's pool on beyond zebra
scrambled egg super and the cat's
quizzer
will no longer be published due to
hurtful depictions in the books
so we've got the school system but then
also
dr seuss enterprises the people that
control dr seuss's legacy control his uh
control everything they're throwing them
under the bus too
they're they're taking part in the
metaphorical book burning that's how bad
it's gotten
you know i see all this now that dr
seuss and of course dr seuss is
cancelled
listen some of us have been have been
warning you
about this for for years now um
every they're coming for everybody
everybody
if you were a prominent person an author
a historical figure
a politician anything
and it's someone who existed
well i i used to say it was like if it
was if you if you existed 40 years ago
or earlier
you're gonna be canceled but now we
could probably move that up and say
if you existed 20 years ago or earlier
10 years ago
everyone's going to get it of course
they're going to come for dr seuss
and yeah if you go back in history you
go back to people author it doesn't
matter anyone
who lived 60 years ago 70 80 90 years
ago
yes they're going to have views
that are not acceptable by our modern
standards
and if they were prominent people
they'll probably have expressed those
views
in some form that's the case for
everyone
there was not a person who lived 80
years ago
who did not have at least one viewpoint
that people in modern society especially
on the left would
recoil in heart if they hurt
not not a single person who lived even
80 years ago
you want to go back you want to talk
about 200 years ago 300 years ago forget
about it
so now they're coming for dr seuss um
and i do take this somewhat personally
this is a cancellation that hits me you
know
a little bit more than some of the
others because i i've
as a kid i was a huge dr seuss fan i
partially taught myself to read
using dr seuss books i was i was in the
dr seuss book club i had all the books
and everything
um with the the cat in the hat book
enders and then i had i had the whole i
had the whole dr seuss catalogue up on
the
up on our bookshelf in our house and i
would read i love dr seuss as a kid my
kids love dr seuss
they're still gonna love dr seuss
they're coming for him too now i and you
know i have always said if we are going
to cancel dr seuss
um it shouldn't be for racism it should
be if anything it should be for elder
abuse with the book hop on pop because
that is a really influential to kids and
i've read that to my kids
and now because they've been brainwashed
by that book they think that any time
they see dad
laying on a couch doesn't matter uh
they can just run and jump right on me
elbow right to the gut
i think it has a lot to do with that
book so if we're going to cancel them it
should be for that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated